nice crisp vegetables you can pickle
good onion good iceberg
it smells like Wendy's bro this smells
like Wendy's damn this is good pickle
American cheese on top and on bottom
that requires skill cameras boys okay
good pretty decent quality of meat I'm
impressed
oh my god just sewing it out this is so
in and out no one else puts an entire
onion on their burger it's all so fresh
I am NOT a fan of lettuce below the
burger for me that's a deal-breaker
there's enough flavor the bun is like
perfectly kind of like fresh and crunchy
and everything tastes real in it
we're entering sesame-seed territory
this burger is just sad it's like the
whoever made this ran out of a great
idea oh it's a veggie burger veggie
burger this was made by somebody who's
just like man give it up the dry right
should drive that was pretty juicy yeah
I don't like this one
Wow look at that glued together this is
this is pop food the pickle is the most
important taste in this that's when
you're trying to cover up some you're
like put pickles a lot of pickles on
there this is like the bird that you get
in a cafeteria like there's like a
cafeteria style burger this is honey I
can't even eat that I wanted to bother
to eat that's not even a burger this is
a love your life come on Moses show us
show us about okay
hi I'm tearing up this looks so good
there isn't any wow factor but it's
solid it's so greasy it's weird to say
this but this one tastes the most like
meat you know what they've got they're
kinda like Nikes like you get to point
them out like oh that's my daughter like
you got that like brand recognition just
from looking at it yeah I don't hate it
I don't hate it it's got that whole
marked bun look at that bunch nobody
makes a bun alike the feet of a
McDonald's is how engineered it is they
always taste exactly the same yeah it
tastes great but it's probably bad for
you but first plate to our right is our
favorite so it's five guys I really like
that this is my favorite Oh
Wendy's I don't know I kind of like this
little bit better but I'm sort of like
if you want to five guys because I'm
loyal this is my first time having a
five guys burger and I've heard so much
about it and it's all been BS there's
ain't five guys guys watching send me
some stuff
send me some burgers in the mail please
yeah cuz in the mail in the mail just
maybe they'll just send you some coupons
they read off I want a burger in the
mail please senator in the mail